Замість людного мітингу - одиночний виступ.
Заклик підтримати незалежне розслідування
вбивства Ірини Ноздровської громадськість
не підхопила.
Як і другого січня під Нацполіцією,
акцію під Генпрокуратурою 10 січня
організувала громадська активіста
і близька подруга Ірини Ноздровської
Лідія Гончаренко.
Все треба доказувати, треба слідчі експерименти,
щоб суспільство зрозуміло: так це було
чи не так це було.
Два роки тому Ірина Ноздровська звернулася до Лідії Гончаренко,
активістки зі стажем, що вже
багато років бореться зі столичними забудовниками.
Ірина не знала, як діяти,
коли прокуратура блокувала
справу смертельного ДТП її сестри.
Це переросло у дружбу.
Вона розповідала такі речі
і так полум’яно, що її сестру
вбив наркоман, що її
разом з матір’ю виштовхує
слідчий з кабінету,
викидає їхню сумку і закриває двері.
Тепер Лідія намагається контролювати,
щоб справу вбивства Ірини не звели
нанівець. І вимагає більшої
прозорості слідства.
Для мене головне, щоб не постраждали
невинні,
ті, на яких
могли повісити це вбивство. ... Звісно, всі версії
треба перевіряти, але
починати слід з тих,
хто реально погрожував їй два з половиною роки.
Це ж логічно.
У захисників загиблої Ірини Ноздровської
також накопичилося чимало запитань
до слідчих. Органи досудового розслідування
ознайомили їх лише з частиною
матеріалів справи, і то після зволікань.
Про ДНК на тілі жертви
та інші знахідки адвокати
дізналися з повідомлень у пресі.
Для нас як
для сторони захисту складається
враження, що орган досудового розслідування
щось приховує від нас. …
Притягнути до відповідальності потрібно
тих посадовців, які
з 29 числа до першого
не займалися розшуком Ірини.
Бо більшість доказів були знищені
в цей час, вони були
надзвичайно важливі.
Підозрюваного у вбивстві Юрія Россошанського
затримали на 10-ий день після злочину.
Дивним видається,
що хоча слідство ще триває, а у
громадських активістів та адвокатів вагомі сумніви,
що саме Россошанський справжній
вбивця, перші особи держави
уже зробили передчасні висновки:
З огляду на це, схоже, що слідство
не збирається розкручувати інші версії
цієї непростої справи.
Це непокоїть доньку Ірини -
Анастасію, яка заявила,
що матеріали справи не збігаються зі свідченнями
арештованого Россошинського
і підозрює, що злочин вчинив
не він.